[Music]
so welcome everybody to today's session
we're really excited today to be talking
about you know taking a look at some of
the biggest challenges that we're
currently facing in business today
particularly as you make a shift to the
cloud my name is Chester I'm actually
lead the chrome customer engineering
team and I've been here at Google for
going on six years I'd also like to
introduce Daniel McClure Daniel if you
can just stand up for a moment he's
going to be presenting alongside later
to talk about Warby Parker and how
they're currently leveraging Chrome
enterprise in their corporate offices as
well as their retail sites today so with
that let's get started
so let's take a look today right I think
many of you are familiar with the
current threat landscape today it's
actually quite different from the way
that it looked a few years ago in fact
the very nature of the forces plays have
actually shifted threats no longer
originated from rogue actors right and
what we mean by that is we now actually
have well-funded organizations that
actually have organized attacks so
that's why you know we're seeing so many
of these familiar attacks whether it's
phishing malware social engineering all
of this is increasing not only in volume
but also in sophistication so let's take
a look so what does that mean the
growing amount spent on information
security globally has been unable to put
a stop to the rising number of
cybersecurity breaches year over year in
fact this year the security information
market is forecasted to actually grow
nearly 9%
totalling 124 billion dollars and the
number of targeted breaches in the u.s.
is growing at a rate of 27 percent per
year so what do we do this clearly is
not a winning formula right and so if
we're investing more to address the same
problems but at the same time the number
of incidents continue to increase then
there is a clear and painful disconnect
right I mean this is not gonna end well
simply throwing money at this problem is
not going to solve it so let's take a
look at our current endpoint strategy
the combat these actual risks
organizations are ultimately seeking
endpoint devices that use an OS with an
embedded security module one that is
inherently resistant to viruses as well
as malware by design this enables
automatic support for safety measures
such as two-factor authentication smart
card readers and many more security
features so I want you all to think
about your endpoint computing strategy
and here's why so let's think for a
moment in time instead of managing an
entire fleet of inherently at risk
endpoint devices I want you all to think
about how you can actually control the
threat by moving that endpoint to the
cloud and you can do this by using an
actual secure cloud native solution like
Chrome Enterprise Chrome devices as well
as Chrome browser are secured by design
they do tear end users from you know
falling hostage to harmful attacks and
in the event that one actually prevails
it actually mitigates the impact
so let's talk about what we mean when I
say secure by design
chrome does Chrome devices are designed
from the inception to be fundamentally
different right it's a different
platform different operating system
they're not created by simply throwing
together in OS on a generic commoditized
motherboard or a piece of hardware and
so what we mean by that is regardless of
which om manufacturer that you select
whether it be HP Samsung Asus etcetera
they all build two designs that are
architected by Google so we dictate the
reference design that we use to
different OEMs of choice and with the
specific hardware components that are
engineered to work they work together in
sync with the operating system and vice
versa so each layer of the machine
you're working with works in conjunction
with others in a way that provides a
unique and ultimate ultimately a very
secure environment so when you start
using Chrome devices at work your work
is ultimately stored safely in the cloud
now given the nature of the situation
some files whether it's your user data
your downloaded files your cookies your
cache etc they need to be present on the
actual device right for example
Chromebooks natively encrypt this data
leveraging a built-in Google security
module in fact encryption is enabled by
default on a Chromebook and cannot be
disabled this is regardless of anybody
that uses that device the hardware has a
tamper resistant security module built
in and this is on every Chrome device
that's manufactured today so the
security hardware does more than just
ultimately encrypt the actual data it
performs a multitude of tasks to prevent
software and firmware version rollbacks
it provides tamper evidence and a good
example of that is someone that actually
tries to swap the hardware out like a
hard drive with a different piece of
hardware
additionally there are hardware
components that serve to protect the OS
tampering all Chromebooks use something
called verified boot if you're not
familiar with that verified boot
confirms that the operating system is a
thent ik safe and is Google distributed
in leveraging a build
you cannot boot a corrupted version of
the operating system
in fact there's actually two versions of
the operating system on the device at
all times through the verified boot
process if the OS is found to be
corrupted it can switch to other the
ultimately the second version of the
operating system right which provides
the verified boot check and additionally
having another version of the OS
automatically means that you can update
the background you know procedure for
the operating system without
interrupting the actual users work so B
by having two versions of the operating
system you can do updates in the
background and you can ultimately update
the actual device during the session
which a user is using there are other
benefits to having you know an actual
small footprint of data on the device
first off Chromebooks are cloud native
by design right so unlike traditional
laptops your files and your data are
primarily stored in the cloud
Chromebooks can be set up in an
ephemeral fashion so for those of you
that don't know what the ephemeral means
this means that all user data is wiped
clean after each session whether you can
set a timer you can wipe the device
after a user selects the sign-out or
exit option with chrome devices your
data is kept inaccessible it's kept
offline and it's ultimately kept secure
furthermore let's take a look with
chrome devices there is no longer this
need to continually attend to update
releases and patches right for anything
as I previously mentioned updates to
chrome occur in the background without
direct interaction on behalf of the user
right so they're not you know we're
ultimately as an administrator we're not
pestering or nagging the user with all
these pop-ups and reminders
administrators can rest assured easily
manage their fleet of Chrome Enterprise
devices and ensure that they have the
most up-to-date and secure version of
the operating system in their fleet of
machines it's important to ultimately
note that chrome is in a constant state
of improvement and with continual bug
fixes security enhancements and feature
role by future rollouts on a frequent
basis we keep abreast of the current
threat landscape that occurs on Chrome
enterprise today chrome comes with the
option of leveraging Google Safe
Browsing service right this is the same
service that's available on the consumer
side of things but on the enterprise
side what we do is Google indexes over
trillions of websites and maintains a
database of sites that are known or
suspected to be malicious in the event
that there is a malicious site will
alert the user about the actual site and
will actually give the option to proceed
or not
administrators actually from you know
enterprise and role devices have the
ability to prevent users from going to
those sites altogether so this notion of
leveraging Google's scope and scale has
helped malicious yet how helped kept
malicious apps off devices which is
present in many of the aspect features
that we offer today from from a chrome
enterprise perspective so chrome offers
you know a multitude of enterprise
applications right so if you take a look
at all the different ways to
beyond the browser some of the native
features with chrome browser include the
ability to let's say run a customized
Google Play Store front a lot of
enterprises want these features in
addition to that you can also access lit
legacy applications such as VDI
solutions from partners like Citrix as
well as VMware while still others can
run using Chrome's native ability we
also have the ability to run Android and
Linux applications on many other types
of devices as well so Chrome browser has
long used sandboxing to Kate to actually
contain threats with browser tabs Chrome
apps in the overall Chrome browser
process Chromebooks take this to an
actual further step by ensuring that all
Android Linux and OS processes are kept
separate and contained from each other
so Google recently actually introduced
site isolation which provides additional
protection making it easy even harder
for untrustworthy websites to access or
steal information from your accounts as
well as other sites so now with all
those extensions that you run on Chrome
you know how do we actually know that
we're actually vetting and securing
these actual extensions so what Google
does behind the scenes is we constantly
enforce a rigorous control on what's
available in the Chrome Web Store today
we implement processes such as extension
reviews both manual as well as automated
some of these might include fingerprint
you know analysis reputation analysis
and we also have added a new feature
which no longer accepts obfuscated
JavaScript files
so let's take a look at the management
policies chrome provides admins the
ability to enforce very very granular
controls these controls offer
administrators exactly what they can and
cannot enforce to be installed and run
on a Chromebook as an admin I can
dictate which policies and app or apps
can be permitted to be installed which
are automatically installed which apps
can be also force installed and pinned
to the toolbar I can also blacklist apps
which can be forbidden altogether this
extends further to determine which sites
can perform what actions or even
prevents users from visiting specific
sites lastly if you enter your corporate
password on a site that isn't corporate
owned we actually use this at Google
today but you'll actually get a
notification that your password was used
on a third-party site this is a new
feature which eliminates potential
phishing usage by tricking a user into
entering their corporate credentials on
a site that might appear to be
legitimate now let's talk about Google
Play protect so play protect scans all
the apps in the App Store by leveraging
our AI fed by billions of data points we
look at everything from pinpointing
where to look to which results in a very
low number of PHA or potentially harmful
apps right so play protect also utilizes
something called attestation this is a
safety net at a station API it provides
app developers the ability to determine
if their app is actually running on a
genuine Android platform and ultimately
developers can also use the verify apps
API to query the status of play protect
for mitigation as well as remediation so
let's take a look at how all of these
pieces
come together and work together which
ensures that we protect the users and
their data as well as your data and how
we keep you safe so that here's a common
attack for phishing right
in this scenario a phishing attacker
will conduct research by gathering
information let's say about your
corporate employees they might even
craft a highly targeted email tricking
employees and users into thinking hey
this is a legitimate message employees
are scammed into downloading malicious
attachments they might even give up
their password or share sensitive data
so how do we you don't sort of address
this by stopping the actual scams we do
actually three things on the platform
first off if you're leveraging Gmail we
use machine learning to identify
phishing emails and prevent them from
reaching inboxes all together but let's
say you're not using Gmail right chrome
warns employees before clicking on
suspicious links that leads to dangerous
actual sites
additionally security keys help prevent
hackers from using stolen passwords to
access employee accounts real quick
question I probably won't be able to see
you all here but quick show of hands how
many folks out there are actually using
hardware security keys today very few so
let's take a look at an actual second
common attack ransomware right I think
many of you are familiar with this with
ransomware things are a bit different
right ransomware is designed to block
access to a computer system until a sum
of money is paid right so out of the
gate I want you all to remember that the
Chromebook data model limits the data
that can be held at ransoms since very
very little if anything is designed to
be on the device to begin with
right and what we mean by that
additionally is that executables MSI
files they can't be installed they can't
run they can't run locally plain and
simple on a Chromebook we talked a good
deal about malicious applications
earlier and just a bit ago we even
discussed the security and protection
controls that we use in Google Play as
well as the Chrome Web Store and I want
to highlight that even in the unlikely
event of an exploit right the scope is
contained and its impact limited by
Chrome's inherent sandboxing model
here's a really interesting question
that I get all the time you know the
question that comes up is why do I not
need antivirus on my Chrome device so
you know a quick explanation of this is
you know much conventional wisdom has
led us to the conclusion that in order
to secure our devices we need to
basically have a stack of product to
assist with securing that actual device
if your genuine interest is in keeping
your operating systems virus free I
think that the you know the the asking
what we've done here is design one in
which virus control of irises cannot
install on themselves to begin with
which is exactly what Chrome OS is not
only does this result in inherently more
secured devices by design but it saves
you a boatload of virus protection
subscription licenses overall and of
course because the threat landscape is
very very dynamic right continually
evolving and changing it's critical I
think for all of us to keep our devices
in your fleet as current as possible so
as we discussed earlier the background
updating capability of Chrome OS ensures
that this happens seamlessly
it happens without any direct
interaction and it happens on behalf of
the end-user because in ministers have
the ability to dictate when this
actually happens this gives everybody in
the enterprise the maximum amount of
protection with minimal if any effort
and with that I'd like to welcome Daniel
McClure from Warby Parker on the stage
all right good afternoon everybody
miss Esther mentioned I'm Daniel McClure
manager of tech services I've been with
the company for five years now I just
celebrated my five-year anniversary on
Sunday so technology services is the
team that's responsible for managing the
users and devices across to corporate
locations one in New York City and one
in Nashville a manufacturing facility
that's about an hour and a half north of
New York City where we actually cut and
pop our lenses into into frames and then
we are close to a hundred retail
locations as of today so right now the
landscape looks like about 2,000 users
3,500 different endpoint devices 225
internet connections that are all trying
to be down as much as possible and I
have a team of five support engineers so
one of the reasons that I've been able
to keep such a lean efficient team is
that over the past over the past five
years I've been I've tried ingrain a
culture of self-service really
empowering the end user using any any
any anything I can grab from my toolkit
to really leverage and remove any kind
of blockers that the typical IT manager
would see anything like I don't have
admin access on my computer I need
access to more services I need my
accounts unlocked and my passwords reset
so again really pushing a lot of a lot
of the work back onto the user to kind
of remove
move IT as a blocker from from getting
things done so I I never wanted to be an
IT team that is an impedance to work I
want to help like push people into into
the future the problem with this is that
as we kind of push users into a more
self-service and user empowering model
we have to do so like very thoughtfully
to make sure that we're striking just
that perfect balance between user
experience and security and I think that
we've done a really good job internally
so a few different things that were that
we're doing that have simultaneously
increased our users experience but also
increased our security posture would be
something like how we onboard a user so
unlike other management platforms if
you're using G suite and G suite
enterprise and Chrome Enterprise not
only do you have the availability to
manage the device itself by ensuring
that you know it's fully encrypted the
screen is locking after a certain period
of time and that it's booting into an
operating system that it should be
booting into it hasn't been tampered
with you're also able to manage the
users experience the experience from a
user perspective as well so as an
example
on day one a Warby Parker employee will
start they'll come into the office
they'll get the tour and their G suite
user is sitting in an organizational
unit that has no access to anything they
can they can look at Gmail they can look
at calendar and they can change some of
their settings and we do this because if
the credentials for these newly created
accounts ever get out is a big big
problem so we just want to silo them off
as much as possible the first
introduction the first course that
somebody goes through in their tenure at
Warby Parker is a class where they're
kind of led through an introduction to
the hardware and introduction to Google
and then enrolling their their user into
multi-factor authentication so within
the first few hours that they've been
with Warby Parker they they understand
they've been explained to what
multi-factor is
are more incentivized to go home and
kind of enable two-factor authentication
on their own services but as a company
because we enforce this across the
entire domain
we're just much more secure at that if
that day one crossroad so all of this
happening within the first couple hours
we then move their user into an OU you
that has more departmental specific
access and they have everything they
need to kind of get off and going
something else that we've done because
of the security posture of these devices
and the policies that we are pushing
down into chrome we do move back up a
little bit I mentioned we have a
Nashville office it's about 350 people
that work in the Nashville area and a
hundred and twenty of those work solely
from home they never come into the
office so there's a big piece of this
this picture that we cannot manage and
that is their internet connection so we
can push as many policies to the devices
we want in the users account but if
somebody has a slow internet connection
there's really nothing we can do about
that
so typically VPN has been a big friction
point in IT anything from needing to
request access and submitting a ticket
getting software installed and then also
that penalty that it can take on on your
internet connection typically everybody
has a fast internet connection so we
really don't see that in that speed
penalty but for a lot of our users
working from home they might be limited
to like a megabyte down or a megabit
down and like point-five up so very slow
internet connection adding that penalty
on to it is just untenable so again to
kind of loop back around because we're
able to manage these devices at such
granularity we can ensure they're full
disk encryption verified boot we have
kind of all agreed internally that it's
okay to start moving some of these
private services out into the public you
know making sure that HTTPS is
everywhere multi-factor is on and we can
allow these work-from-home users to
do what they have to do without the need
of a VPN in our retail shifting gears a
little bit to talk about retail in our
retail environment we probably ship
three to four laptops to each individual
store and these stores can range from
the number of employees from 25 on up to
50 so it's very important as shifts
change throughout the day to have these
shared devices within our within our
retail stores we we using other
operating systems have tried to have
this very shared environment where you
know somebody comes in in the morning
they take a laptop off the charging rack
somebody comes in midday they need to
grab a laptop they have to do
front-of-house back at house duties
there was a laptop assignment where like
two to three people were assigned to
each individual laptop this caused a lot
of issues so we were able to kind of
replace those with Chrome OS and chrome
devices because of that like
out-of-the-box shared experience while
maintaining this full disk encryption
screen lock after about a minute keep in
mind that these associates are
interacting with systems that touch pH I
so everything that we do has to be very
mindful around keeping within HIPAA
compliance so that's that's really
allowed us to again keep a very low
number of laptops kind of out in the
wild and have that shared experience as
well because anybody with a Warby Parker
account can can authenticate in so while
we're doing this we also have to be you
know very aware of kind of these three
big threat vectors that are going on
right now and you know as we get around
solving for one the others just kind of
move into the back of our head until it
comes in shoulder taps us and says they
want to exploit you need to do all these
things so Warby Parker kind of being
born in the era of like a SAS based SAS
based services malware has always kind
of been top of mind and with the ability
to block any kind of
potentially nefarious extensions
something that could potentially be
exfiltrating data anything that kind of
bubbles up any kind of security alert
that our legal team may may come across
their plate and they request that we we
block these extensions has been very
very helpful very beneficial and also
when it comes to malware because
everything is siloed and spam boxed into
its own little realm each Chrome browser
tab is its own environment if any
incident is occurring on one individual
tab it will not proliferate out into the
rest and into the into the operating
system as an example of something that
kind of shoulder taps you as a day one
there was the chrome exploit about a
month ago where everybody was saying
this is a zero day you must update we
were able to mitigate this risk very
quickly by going into G Swede unpinning
the operating system and forcing all the
devices to update so something like that
really saves on a lot of engineering
resources credential threat kind of goes
hand-in-hand a little bit with malware
you know again we just want to make sure
that all of our devices are running the
latest version of Chrome and that
they're actually booting into a version
of Chrome OS that has not been modified
hasn't been tampered with just to ensure
that there are systems very securely and
then of course phishing which is kind of
the big hot topic I think I read
yesterday I want to note another session
that 90% of all data leaks start with
phishing attack so again ensuring that
devices are just up-to-date regularly
checking in any devices that we may use
for for any kind of digital signage
making sure that they're locked down and
cannot be interacted with as someone may
just naturally move to one and start
checking their email we want to make
sure that each device has its own place
and is doing the thing that it should be
doing and we now have the option of
choosing what flavor of multi-factor
we'd like to enforce across which ones
we like to revoke so very recently we we
can now turn off
sms multi-factor authentication so NIST
has come out and essentially said you
know SMS is no longer secure
it's better than nothing but it's still
as you as you move into like the
different levels of different
multi-factor the user experience
actually gets much better as they get
more secure so SMS being less secure the
user experience isn't great
you have the Authenticator application
which user experience improves and
security improves at the same time you
have the screen prompt where you unlock
your phone and tap yes again user
experience improves security improves
and hopefully you know the dream at some
point is actually get you to eff tokens
everywhere where it's just a touch of a
button then you're you're into that
system so again there's this there's
this common thought that as you're
increasing security the user experience
drops and you have to make some of these
you have to kind of negotiate with
yourself and make exception somewhere
but we've organically kind of moved into
this realm where we're increasing the
users experience by granting them access
they need but improving security by
doing it in a very smart way so kind of
all of this to say Chrome OS at Warby
Parker is the most popular computer
operating system we have well over a
thousand devices and it's been it it has
helped us scale in a in a very secure
way so there's one kind of big
achievement there
the second big achievement is kind of
sitting on the beyond quark model the
VPN les model and it has helped us to
decrease our VPN use by close to 90
percent
we certainly have teams that still rely
on and still need it but we're working
on that that remaining 10 percent so
that is what I have to say about that
all right so in the event that you
really like this movie please visit our
website if you have any questions on
enterprise security as it relates to
Chrome Enterprise
[Music]